la competencia en cannes se convirtió en
maratón cinematográfico con cintas
filmadas en tahití corea del sur y una
historia avenida de bélgica
[Música]
ah
el director catalán albert serra está
por primera vez en la historia en la
competencia con pacific sión una extraña
excursión a la polinesia francesa
en paz y fiction serra muestra un
paraíso pero de corrupción administrado
por un diplomático francés
magistralmente interpretado por benoit
magimel aquí se tocan en filigrana temas
candentes como la colonización o los
tristeza ensayos nucleares que francia
hizo en polinesia en los años 60 y 70
[Música]
el maestro japonés ha premiado con la
palma de oro en 2018 hirokazu kore-eda
vuelve a la competencia de cannes con
broker una cinta filmada en corea del
sur kuchar más un progreso
cómo
identificar en el conducto
en esta película kore eda vuelve a
explorar el concepto de familia pero a
través del prisma de los niños
abandonados la cinta comienza con una
joven madre que abandona a su recién
nacido y que luego teje lazos con dos
hombres que se dedican al tráfico de
niños robados
[Música]
el prodigio del cine belga lucas don
estremeció a la clase con su segundo
largometraje close a sus 31 años don
presentó esta película basada en su
juventud sobre la amistad efusiva entre
dos chicos
[Música]
y también sobre mí
leo y emmi son inseparables cuando estos
dos chicos comienzan el bachillerato
tienen que enfrentar preguntas
indiscretas y humillaciones leo decide
entonces separarse lo que es
insoportable para su amigo klaus es una
cinta brillante e impecable que causó
lágrimas y mucha emoción quizás el
ingrediente del mejor cine
[Música]